did mijin mousse survive what's with
Polly Cooper's disappearing act and
exactly why is the black hood wreaking
havoc in Riverdale all that and so much
more on Sweetwater secrets lapel amoebas
I'm Liana Gill era and I know you're all
out there frantically tripping about
chapter 16 a watcher in the woods so
let's get straight to it now remember
this is our Sweetwater Secrets
after-show so if you haven't watched
episode 203 play away for everyone else
get excited cuz I've got interviews with
KJ Appa
KC Carr and Lily Reinhardt about this
episode's most shocking moments but
first it's time to kick things off with
the biggest headlines of the week in the
blue and gold breakdown all right guys
the biggest news of the night Mitch and
moose survived so suck it black hood you
didn't win this time now mage is
perfectly fine because our heroic moose
used his body to shield her from the
bullets and fingers crossed he'll be out
of that hospital bed soon but yes we can
all be so thankful that they're okay
next up the black hood unveils his jerk
plan in a manifesto that was sent to
Alice Cooper he revealed that he's
targeting the quote sinners of Riverdale
now at this point I definitely think
that how Cooper is somehow involved with
the black hoods antics because sending
that envelope to the Cooper's is the
perfect way to cover up his tracks I am
the man who shot the adulterer pops and
lastly they're restless and shirtless
meet the watchdog's of Riverdale at the
red circle yes Archie formed an intense
neighborhood watch in order to protect
the residents of Riverdale like Barnes
seriously I mean Ethel should we be
worried now here's a fun fact for you
the red circle is based off of a real
comic book series that featured the
superhero set in the archie universe
sneaky-sneaky Riverdale writers so what
does KJ Appa think of Archie's shirtless
crusade take a look at what he told me
he forms the red circle mm-hmm he's out
he's ready to help people how fun was it
for you to just get with all the
Bulldogs that was fun actually to knit
with Charles there des was one of his
piercings on the show too which was
go he was excited it was kind of that
was weird those well just a bunch of
shirtless jocks behind behind me but now
is good a lot of guys thought they were
like okay yeah not a good thing I think
was cool we will find you now were you
guys intimidated or oh so elated by the
red circle
it's the comments right now but also
let's keep focusing on the hot and heavy
of this week's episode in seven seconds
in heaven now this week is going out to
Betty and Jughead for this passionate
smooch in the red and black newsroom
[Music]
but we also got to see Kevin Keller get
a little action while cruising Fox for
us now here's a kasey kahne had to tell
me about Kevin's romantic thrills in
season two Kevin's given a love interest
maybe more than one
we'll see what we'll sees about that I I
love how they've written Kevin in the
season I think he's gonna explore all
different kinds of love interests which
is kind of cool and different and that's
all I can really say but it's it's
exciting and fun and and scary and new
and it's it's great who would you guys
like to see Kevin get foxy with this
season I'm personally hoping for more
Kevin and loose moments but we will see
moving on to hisses and kisses first up
in hisses I hated seeing the fact that
Jughead is having such a hard time at
Southside High that is such a creepy
school to be in and an additional mega
hiss to juggy lying to Betty about his
bullies beat down told you that
motorcycle was risky come on Betty
you're smarter than that another kiss of
the night hyerin being truly terrifying
and Hermione Lodge being is straight out
of to Veronica
enough is enough girl either tell us
your problem or zip it
or better yet Hyrum will do it for you
and my kisses go out to the return of
Ethel although I'm sorry about your
almost barbed like kidnapping girl and a
lovely kiss to the introduction of tawny
topaz Forsyth Pendleton Jones the third
now she could be trouble down the line
for Betty and Jughead but for now I
appreciate the fact that she's looking
out for jugg in school so thank you girl
and I'm sending another kiss to Reggie
because he's bringing us an unexpected
laughs in a super dark season - oh
you're nursery's hot cuz like what if
you pop a boner down like a sponge bath
thank you very much for that Reggie and
this last one is a little bit of a
twofer
I'm sending kisses to the fact that we
finally got to see Pauly Cooper again
but massive hisses - the fact that she's
leaving I'm going again luckily it seems
Lily Reinhardt is not too pleased either
now here's what she had to say about
Pauline piecing out Andy may be massive
spoiler that I accidentally stumbled on
we see in episode three Pauly's like I'm
out I'm an unwed mother carrying my
cousin's babies I am the poster child
for sin how is that gonna shake up
things for Betty not having her sister
there it's like an ally built into her
house yeah I think Betty feels a little
cornered sometimes by her parents
especially alice is so aggressive and
dominant I think Betty kind of felt like
she had an ally with Polly there and
that's why she tried so hard to find
Polly in season one so to have gone
through all of that and then to have
Polly leave so early after coming back
it's really devastating for Betty but
there's so many things that Betty's
dealing with and so much on her plate
that she can't like stop and cry about
it she has to just keep moving on but I
think the biggest thing is that she lost
an ally someone on her side
well luckily time moves pretty slowly in
Riverdale for the moment so it's not
like she's gonna be missing the birth of
the babies quite yet
oh god I just touched on something
touched on something
Lily no I had to check what did I just
do not Polly's baby's alright vixens
it's time to start hitting the comments
with your top kisses and kisses of
episode 203 and tell me your top
theories and thoughts for what's next or
you can follow me on Twitter and we can
freak out over every little Riverdale
detail together now I'll be back with
your preview episode of chapter 17 the
town that dreaded sundown but in the
meantime give this video a like and hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel so
you never miss an episode of sweet water
secrets bye
[Music]